it's great to Welcome to the program
today Adam Rogers who's a senior Tech
correspondent at Insider and also author
of the book full spectrum one of his
recent articles is going to be the uh
Catalyst for our conversation today
called sure Twitter and Facebook have
deepened polarization just not in the
way you think Adam really great having
you on today I appreciate your time oh
thanks for having me I appreciate it so
okay I mean let's let's kind of go right
to the punch line and then maybe we'll
work backwards from there so it's common
to think social media
has made polarization worse I think
there's a number of ways that people
would assume that that's the case filter
Bubbles and Echo Chambers probably is
one and you know we can kind of list
others what is the way in which you
believe social media platforms have
deepened American political polarization
well I'll tell you a couple of things
that that surprised me in the reporting
for this and this is why I wanted to do
the story the first thing is that while
I think
um I I would have said before I started
calling people that that the problem was
an echo chamber a filter bubble
epistemic closure right was that oh we
get on social media and then we we
somehow in some way tend to assort with
people who have the same political and
Views as we do and then maybe the same
cultural abuses we do and we don't hear
about anything outside that and I think
that was fairly commonly accepted it
turns out that among social scientists
it's actually not the case social
scientists have not found evidence for
that and as one of them said to me like
there's there are worse Echo Chambers in
real life you know IRL we tend to assort
that way and we don't turn into
Political
freak Show you know in real life
particularly so if it's not filter
bubbles it's not an echo chamber
I would have said oh well obviously it's
the reverse right you would say oh it's
uh it's that you we go online and then
we're exposed to like repugnant views or
views that are repugnant to us and we
think oh those that that guy is terrible
like I don't want anything to do with
whatever that person is saying and
anything that they believe in any of the
stuff that they have in the background
of their you know chat window or
whatever but that doesn't happen either
when you actually do tests when
researchers do tests on this people
don't experience those kind of feelings
and we can talk about some of the
studies say in those experiences so the
question then is all right what happens
if we accept that polarization is
increasing and that does seem to be true
and if we accept that polarization is
something that's kind of independent of
like no some one political group
actually is saying repugnant thing like
objectively repugnant things and if we
accept that there are things that that
are weirdly
politicized but shouldn't be political
and you and I disagree with what those
things are but we you could say
something like how does something like
climate change become political how does
something like what car you drive or
what if you drive a car or what your
favorite drink is whether it's alcoholic
or not how does those things become
political or polarizing and yet they do
so okay that's a long run up by way of
saying that this is a researcher he's a
computational social scientist and Peter
tornberg he's also trained as a
physicist and he's interested in
complexity Theory so the way that small
things turn into big things basically
and what he says is if you if you model
uh digitally people in a large Social
Network all it takes is really two
conditions to get real serious bad
polarization all you have to do first of
all is make sure that people are
connecting with
with non-local connections so that means
strangers people at a distance people
they wouldn't ordinarily connect with
distant from themselves both in in terms
of their demographic characteristics and
also literally like Geographic distance
and then you you kind of turn up our
tendency to distrust things that are
unfamiliar to us or the positive way to
say that is trust things that are
familiar
all you have to do is make those two
dials happen and you start to see the
the people the little digital The Sims
inside this world begin to polarize on
things that are not just political but
things that are cultural as well what
researchers call affective polarization
it's very different than ideological
polarization or red blue divide this is
stuff like uh you know if you drive an
F-150 or a Prius things that are that
are choices that have political
components but are not themselves
political choices if you see what I mean
and that kind of that effective
polarization and the demonization the
attendant demonization of people who are
not in your effectively polarized group
are the things that uh researchers worry
the most about it seems that context
must matter to some degree though
because there are situations that people
find themselves in where they encounter
those who at least
exist generally in very disparate places
they maybe come together for a
conference or for travel or whatever the
case would be so you can you can kind of
make that a reality uh and you can kind
of put these components together and
they don't seem to explode in the same
way that often takes place on social
media is that something about the
disinhibiting context of social media
that maybe is an additional Factor
yeah so that's a really good point all
of us have had the experience of being
of having a a perfectly Pleasant meal
with somebody who's political whose
political abuse you find repugnant
obviously that has its limits if they're
somebody who wants to you know put you
in a camp maybe you don't want to be
sitting in the same dinner table with
them but but you see what I mean yes so
yes that context matters a lot
um and and there is the factor that
social media has an anonymizing effect
even if you have your real identity on
there you're at a distance it's a little
like just shouting at a television
screen and the television screen shouts
back you know but
um there's also the fact of the way the
social networks themselves work these
are these are by and large depending on
what you're on and what you're using
for-profit networks and and what they
depend on is our attention and
engagement because they're trying to use
our identities to sell ads against
and so in addition to the the factors
that tornberg came up with like how how
does polarization happen in groups who
are exposed to each other in these
particular network with these particular
kinds of network effects the the social
networks themselves turn up their own
dial for um linking our identities to
our posts so they they ask you know who
you are essentially with everything that
you look at and everything that you post
and then privileging the loudest voices
because those get the most engagement
um and those tend to be the most extreme
so you know again we've all had the
experience of tootling Along on Twitter
or on Facebook and then seeing something
that was just astonishingly terrible
right and your first instinct is to want
to be like that's astonishingly terrible
which plays right into the way the the
economics of this thing work um and that
increases polarization right it
increases our our sense that everything
that we're doing has a political
component
there are some like for example Jonathan
height comes to mind who
has a sort of maybe different diagnosis
for what's going on than you but one of
his suggestions is
you can have an anonymous handle on
social media but the platform should
know exactly who you are so like for
example if I want to operate on Twitter
as you know Anonymous elephant 2655 I
can do that but when I create the
account I have to provide Twitter with
my driver's license or whatever proving
that I really am who I say I am and that
that would reduce the disinhibiting
nature of social media to some degree do
you agree with that
um
I have the there's a Hemingway line
isn't it pretty to think so I mean there
first of all I have concerns
look I'm not as much of an expert as as
Jonathan is but I have some concerns
about having identity be in escrow in
these for these for-profit companies as
well I don't I don't think that they're
trusted actors here I would say that
there are the internet could have gone a
very different way uh in the mid-2000s
let's say right where the companies that
turned into ad agencies effectively and
uh could have instead said we are going
to first of all create a way that to
build identity into the base layer of
the internet in the same way that like
they use that in email we're built into
the base layer of the internet we forget
I think that Twitter and Facebook and
Google or websites they're fundamentally
they're just websites they're huge
they're complicated they're they're
they're they're vast they're
transnational but they're just websites
and what what what the people who
designed and built the internet chose
not to do because they chose a more a
profit-oriented motive was not was to
not build identity into that base layer
to not build ways for all of us to be
able to control our own identity in our
own self-expression on the internet and
this is something I sound uh I've gone
um uh I've gone very like boing boing on
this I think
um to to say a thing like what was what
was supposed to happen was that we were
supposed to have tools to make it easy
to have a website an RSS feed and if you
want to have a what we used to call a
Blog and you now might call a sub stack
or medium or whatever if you want to
have that you can have that if you want
to sell stuff from your own little shop
here are some here's Machinery where you
can do that retailing and fulfillment
but instead we seeded all of that stuff
to these big transnational companies so
you know so I'm not sure that they're
they are not who I would trust to um to
be the Arbiters as we've seen to be good
Arbiter good faith Arbiters of of
political or other kinds of conversation
online although and so I'll I'll
contradict myself just very briefly and
say the the um I think another
experience that has become shared in
common is we might all have small uh you
know DM chat groups right like uh group
chats or small groups that were where
you're in the DMS on Twitter or
Invitation Only very tightly moderated
groups on Facebook those kind of smaller
groups sometimes Group by Affinity
sometimes Group by social connections
that are not on the internet sometimes
that are those become very positive
those are those are where my meaningful
social connections are at this point in
a way
um and sometimes they're arbited through
those through the big social networks
through a Twitter or through Facebook or
whatever and sometimes they're not but
the but because of their size and
because they are they are more tightly
controlled not for for
um like affective ideological engagement
but for some kind of emotional
engagement that's more meaningful they
tend to be more positive spaces when it
comes to you mentioned these these
companies platforms websites as the
Arbiters here
it seems pretty clear at this point that
the platforms generally benefit from the
entire way that they have operated
including boosting the voices that as
you talk about increase the polarization
loud voices Etc we kind of understand
that is it fair to say that because of
that they simply can't be counted on to
try to work on this problem is it that
flat out or are there ways to
incentivize Facebook and Twitter or
whoever
um to actually try to fix this problem
rather than profit from it yeah I don't
know that's that's such a good question
and we see it going on right right now I
mean that's the the that's
at one of at the heart of what is
happening with Elon Musk and Twitter for
example right is is is he's you know
clearly interested in in uh in elevating
voices from the right he's engaging with
them himself
and so the question is well like how do
you deal with that if you know that a
lot of those voices are also you know
trolls are also gonna uh gonna
potentially hurt people you know send
out sort of stochastic terrorism against
trans people or against Jews or against
all the people who sort of are are the
like uh targets of the day you know
horribly so and and so what are we so
the response to that has been like
essentially weirdly to me let the market
deal with it right well he's going to
lose all his advertisers if he does that
that's sort of our response and and that
may happen right that could or the
advertisers could then pressure him and
say you can't do that or we won't
advertise so it becomes the what we
trust as a society is that the the same
profit motives that got us here will get
us out and uh you know that's the thing
that we could all perhaps be polarized
online about whether we believe will
happen or not yeah I mean I guess I
would say I'm depressed I don't have
solid evidence to think that that's
exactly the way it would work absent
some kind of uh countervailing Force but
probably a conversation for for for the
next conversation uh we've been speaking
with Adam Rogers who's a senior Tech
correspondent at Insider also author of
the book full spectrum and we're going
to link to the article that's been the
source for today's conversation Adam
really appreciate your time today thank
you
my pleasure thanks for having me